[Music]
if you want to do this fun split hem
opposite stuff whether it's an teaspoon
or in spin poi foo is really important
Polly foo is a movement of your arms and
a lot of the fun patterns and splitting
offices with the poi also use split time
opposites with the arms sometimes in in
spin and sometimes in if you spin this
often goes wrong because our shoulders
are shoulder width apart and as you move
from this position to this position one
of the shoulders and leads and people
tend to let that arm get over there way
ahead of the other arm and they go like
this with their arms when you try to do
that with poi you can kind of do the
patterns but none of the geometry adds
up you don't end up with these nice with
a top bottom reflection there's no
symmetry so instead of looking you know
like this and I don't do it perfectly
but instead of looking like this it
looks like more like this typically it's
not what you want
so if you dial in your poi foo it'll be
easier to add poi and one of my ongoing
philosophies is often if you use an
object in the world you will see results
faster than say just using a mirror in
this instance I'm gonna use a tree so
now I have something in the real world
and that will give me visceral feedback
instead of just visual feedback because
I find if I use a mirror when I don't
have the mirror I lose the skill well if
I use an object I can keep the skill you
want to imagine a circle with four clear
contact points you connect the dots and
split em opposites from the hands pass
on the side above each other in the
middle on the other side mmm boom what
people do is this they let one hand pass
the center way ahead of the other one so
I can use that tree
to bounce off that centerline I pass
through the side bounce bounce bounce I
can switch to the other side
bounce bounce I'm lining my center of
with the edge of the tree so that if my
fingers touch the tree together I know
I've got good play foo and I can close
my eyes now and learn to have a sense a
felt sense of whether I'm on track or
not because if I'm going boom boom boom
boom
I know I don't have it right and I
learned to feel it if I learn to feel it
I can back away from the tree and
imagine the tree is there and practicing
back and forth like that I will
eventually dial in my split time
opposites with the arms boy foo then
when I add the poi back everything works
a little easier because the poi foo is
good if I stop in the middle one circle
will be above the other circle you can
even just use the doorway and then you
can just practice one half the circle at
a time
turn around and you can practice the
other half or you know move from side to
side of the doorway Nick reporting from
outside Leviathan studio
[Music]